plynna hello and i we kind of matched
today yeah today today is uh our
two-year wedding anniversary by the way
yeah congrats yeah nice nice we made it
can we just say that
can we just say that this morning i woke
up no actually he woke up earlier so he
left so then i see a text message from
him and i'm like oh it's definitely
gonna be like happy anniversary instead
it was
man because we were gone this weekend he
was like man the eight sleep really does
make you feel more rested i feel amazing
and i was like thanks you too
okay
i did text her that i was like man i'm
refreshed today
[Laughter]
your ass is not you know you're just
kind of like a little groggy then all of
a sudden you sleep on it again you're
like let's roll so i need to let you
know
all right uh what's the first topic elon
musk what's he what is elon doing i
don't know what do you think he's doing
okay so he if you haven't heard already
elon musk wants to end his 44 billion
deal to buy twitter
but
i mean
this is crazy twitter's board chair
brett taylor said the company is still
committed to closing the deal at the
agreed upon price and plans to pursue
legal action aka sue elon if to enforce
the agreement can they really force him
to buy this company let's go back before
we go forward uh elon said he was going
to buy twitter i think that he actually
was excited about buying twitter i think
he genuinely meant i'm going to buy 20.
you think so yeah 100
i don't think that elon musk uh on a
day-to-day basis is like a master plan
guy i think that he's got like hey
there's a long uh vision and then he
kind of just does whatever he feels like
is the right thing in the moment a great
example is the story of the boring
company they were in a meeting and they
were talking about uh making tunnels and
then all of a sudden he was like how
long would it take us to build a tunnel
and somebody was like well we could
probably get started in like three weeks
he goes well like why don't you guys go
outside right now start digging and see
how far we can get by sunday and it was
friday
and they literally and within two hours
in the parking lot they had a hole in
the ground and so i think that's just
kind of how he is is like he has this
propensity for action and so when he saw
the opportunity to go by twitter i think
he got excited about it he went and he
did it he is going to pay millions and
millions of dollars in fees he's done
calls he talked to the employees he's
dealt with the press like you don't do
all of that because you did you weren't
serious at some point
i also think that his concerns around
the bot problem are very real i don't
anyone who thinks that twitter only has
five percent bots you're living under a
rock or you're an idiot uh they
definitely have more than five percent
bots and
i think that him pulling out of this is
not him trying to like renegotiate the
price i think he's like all right well
i'm not going to buy this this is stupid
uh and he lost interest at some point
what i do think is going to occur though
is that if twitter sues him
this is going to be a big mistake for
twitter if you because
under a court of law they are going to
have to explain a lot of things
and the lawyers aren't just going to be
like the meme
cue the meme well keep keep talking oh
the lawyers oh the meme so elon elon
tweeted this today they said i couldn't
buy twitter then they wouldn't disclose
the bot info now they want to force me
to buy twitter in court now they have to
disclose bot and voting court
do you think he took these photos
specifically for this meme
no well so hold on a second
i let me argue twitter's side for a
second go ahead i
he's he keeps saying that he doesn't
have the bot info but twitter sent him
what they had then he was like that's
not enough then they sent him like the
raw data go do your own analysis elon he
still didn't do it no no
that's twitter's [ __ ] story
but
supposedly allegedly
twitter gave him the twitter feed
but they were rate limiting it to the
point where they gave him less access
than they give their own data customers
didn't they give him the raw data
but they wouldn't let him actually query
the whole thing
so there's a lot of [ __ ] happening
in the shadows right now
at the end of the day it's gonna come
down to
have they been telling the public
five percent or less bots
and is that true because now we're going
to enter a world this isn't just about
elon buying it if it goes to court and
it is proven that there's more than five
percent bots
there becomes a question of is there
fraud here
have there been public filings where the
company is representing something
well that's what i i was reading a whole
article today making the argument that
that's the problem is that there's
misrepresentations
about the data amongst a lot of
companies not just twitter
homes
okay sorry uh so homes like stocks are
in a period of divergence right now um a
lot there okay there's this hedge fund d
shaw shows that in 2021
um
what does it show hold on i had a whole
thing for this oh yeah yeah
it's gotta get the rust off here yeah i
know there was an analysis that looks at
market conditions in a hundred
metropolitan areas around the country to
see which markets are the riskiest
like where there have been the biggest
declines in house and where do they say
well do you want to guess
raleigh nashville austin and
jacksonville
no
no boise austin and phoenix oh okay i i
believe it's just hold on hold on no
that's fall
the riskiest markets over the next 12
months per this company are provo utah
lakeland is that in yeah lakeland and
cape
coral and florida and austin
okay
i feel like they're all just making this
up how do you know what's gonna happen
in the future i don't know but it says
most cities will see a deceleration and
home price is not a crash do you believe
that
well
the home
another piece is a home has four walls
and a roof the home doesn't change if
the willingness of what people are going
to pay for the home changes and that is
driven by nothing more than monetary
policy if there's loose monetary policy
and capital is cheap what do people do
they go borrow the money and they go buy
the home
it's simple if the capital is expensive
then people are going to borrow less
meaning they're willing to pay less and
so if you go ahead and you take a look
guess what the fed's saying they're
going to continue to raise interest
rates which means the capital will be
more expensive which means people will
borrow less they borrow less and they
have less money because their stock
portfolio has gone down that means
they're willing to pay less for the
actual home and home prices come down
this ain't rocket science and
trying to pick which markets or whatever
ends up being kind of a crazy idea
because at the end of the day what
you're ultimately doing is you're trying
to just pick
where it has
prices completely detached from the
value that you can uh obtain
and in places like phoenix it was one of
the best performing real estate markets
over the last two three years in places
like miami in places like um uh what do
you call it uh austin texas those are
some of the best places so if it goes up
fast guess what happens
comes down fast as well it's a fair
point expensive capital all right
i was just looking for places where we
should not move
uh tiger global
today's monday i don't know
right yeah one day is no different than
any other day
tiger global which was one of the
biggest winners of the tech bull market
and kind of one of the biggest losers of
the bear market uh plans to decelerate
the pace of its investments in startups
for two quarters
but
the firm is also on track to raise a new
fund later this year well that's
interesting non-news wait why
ever
everyone's doing this what do you mean
everybody's doing that everyone is
sitting there slowing their pace of
interest the impression that tiger
global was kind of dead but it's not no
tiger global still has tens of billions
of dollars they're still some of the
best investors in the world
and what everyone across the market is
doing here's some inside alpha i talk to
investors all day long and guess what
they all say yeah we're trying to figure
out if uh prices are going to continue
to fall especially in the later stage
of a business
there's much more sensitivity to prices
in the pre-season seed rounds those
prices are still pretty healthy they
didn't fall a bunch
and people are still deploying a lot of
capital there but once you get kind of
series a okay a little slow down series
b and beyond that market is drastically
dried up i know plenty of companies that
are out fundraising they've lowered
their valuations they're having a tough
time uh people having to take flat
rounds down rounds all you know look for
m a all kinds of stuff happening and
it's because remember there's a chain
reaction in the public markets there are
a bunch of hedge funds those hedge funds
have seen their stocks come down because
the fed has been raising interest rates
and conducting quantitative tightening
if you're a hedge fund and you have a
public market portfolio and you're
watching it fall down guess what you do
if you're also happen to be a crossover
fund and invest in the private markets
you immediately say to yourself well the
public market is saying that these
companies are only worth two to five x
revenue i'm not gonna go pay 20 times
revenue in the last round before a
company tries to go public because i'm
going to get screwed so then they say
well we're not paying 20 times revenue
anymore now we're only going to pay five
times revenue well if the series f or
series e investors says i'm only going
to pay five times then very quickly the
series cd and e investors say well hold
on a second we can't invest at 20 times
revenue because the next investor isn't
going to uh um going to invest at that
rate they're only going to invest at
five times revenue so we're going to get
screwed and the chain reaction kind of
works itself through the system where
everyone starts to get kind of slow down
in pace and also re-evaluate the uh
market caps of these businesses because
there is a change to the environment in
capital markets and the private market
is insulated to a degree but it is not
completely immune to it and so tiger
saying hey we're gonna slow down for two
quarters what they're basically saying
is let's just buy time see where the
market kind of settles and then we'll
start to deploy again so these companies
whether it's tiger it's a traditional
venture fund any of these folks they're
not going away they're simply just
saying we don't know we're in the we're
in the eye of the storm
right and as it occurs we just gotta
wait to see what happens and then we'll
start to invest again i just can't
believe that it's sitting on billions of
dollars of dry powder dry powder is
uninvested capital
that's wild nice
damn encyclopedia
all right what's up with prime day okay
uh so i heard that so
prime day is amazon's two-day event with
all these sales wait why fake
isn't this their second one oh oh i'm
not i don't think so is it
i think they have two questions i did
not know that wait what do you mean two
prime days are you not impressed with my
intellectual range hold on no i can go
from talking about monetary policy to
fake prime day it's not impressive if
you ask if it's impressive uh so amazon
has prime day july 12th and 13th is that
what you mean that it's two days well
that one no that one's coming but i
think that they i think they have
another one but go ahead we'll figure
out the details we'll call it prime day
for now
yeah by the way one time i went to an
amazon distribution center is that what
it's called and i saw like all the
packages go it's amazing in there it's
like it's like santa's workshop okay so
um
i don't know if you went because you
were a reporter trying to do a story or
if you were trying to track a package
that you ordered but there's multiple
reasons why you could have been there
could you imagine
i did not surprise me like they gonna
give me my package if by the way if
there's two days july 12th and 13th then
you can't call it prime day
oh that's what they call it all right go
ahead i mean so what's the story so
they've had explosive growth during this
period when they do prime days but
this this deals editor at wirecutter
says that we may not see
the crazy growth year over year that we
have seen before because of things like
inflation people may not be spending as
much money as they once did on things on
days like this but wouldn't you spend
money on this day because
because it's big deals no people
psychologically or money yeah no people
are psychologically prepared for a
recession they're spending less money
and if they're going to spend less money
prime day comes and they just go into
the day saying i'm not buying anything
you think so
i know so because you can see it in the
customers and the consumer no you can
see in the consumer sentiment data is
people believe we are headed towards bad
times and whether they are right or not
the psychology of the consumer ends up
dictating what they do from an actual uh
consumption standpoint and so if you
think we're headed to bad times guess
what people start to do you know what i
need to cut back on the coffee i buy i
need to not go out to eat as much
anymore i need to do this and they start
to get in the mentality of save don't
spend as much and and they become uh
less fixed remember food at home
was always expensive
yeah it's not any better but but still
it ends up being a psychological shift
has occurred the federal reserve started
last november and december talking tough
saying we are going to destroy demand
destroy demand means they are going to
financially incentivize you not to want
to buy things
that's what destroyed demand means like
if you take the federal reserve's word
we are going to destroy demand and you
translate it to street language
they are going to punish you until you
no longer want to buy things
they are destroying the demand for goods
and services guess what it's working and
so when there is a day or two like prime
day or days
there's less demand because the federal
reserve is literally beating people over
the head with monetary policy saying
you do not want to buy things
right destroy demand consume less it's
almost like they use big words to
confuse people but if they just came out
and they said we're gonna punish
everyone until they don't want to buy
things anymore people oh [ __ ] i probably
i should save some money
well it's interesting though that from
putting that aside walmart target and
best buy among others are holding
competing deals events to coincide with
amazon prime day
like can you imagine you're he's reading
the comments right now you're so big
what
i'm you're so big and you're such a
competitor that you kind of force all
your other competitors to
up the ante and do dl days to compete of
course target like did it one day in
advance
end quote repeat line
what oh
somebody said that in the chat
i mean
go ahead next
we do not speak politics here it's not
politics
um nasa do my best
its first full color scientific images
taken by the james webb space telescope
monday and tuesday this is cool okay so
why is it yes it is cool i agree but
like why do we have to do this reveal
like first biden is gonna unveil the
first color photo today at 5 00 pm
eastern nasa will release the rest of
the images on tuesday at 10 30 a.m
eastern why this like build up just
release the photos to the people i don't
get it how do you know uh
how do you know that it's a real photo
oh come on question i just asked why do
you think it's this big reveal because
it's cool
people are uh excited about stuff like
this i think they should be like the
hubble telescope like when that has like
a new imagery or something people get
excited this is cool it's first caller
version yeah and and so this is
interesting um
i think they spent a billion dollars oh
yeah 10 billion sorry this long awaited
milestone will set the stage for the
rest of the 10 billion dollar
telescope's mission to rework our
understanding of how the universe
evolved from the earliest galaxies to
today
billion dollars we got people hungry in
this country
we got people suffering
and we're shipping tens of billions of
dollars to a country that we supposedly
aren't at war in and also we're spending
10 billion on the satellite
to not do anything about the future but
to understand the past
interesting
i'm just saying tupac had it right oh my
god
do you remember what he said no i don't
remember the exact quote but he
basically was like they got money for
war but they ain't got money to feed the
poor
fair point my guy was
[Music]
[Applause]
real quick before i let you go i do want
to make sure that we mention uh
yesterday was ranger's first birthday so
happy birthday to my friend ranger uh
that the little pup uh that little pup
is now a
big
big dog now like the actual big dog uh
see did you get that did you get that
practice in the dad jokes uh the best
part about it though is if you're a
one-year-old dog it's really like you're
seven
oh yeah right dog ears get it like
just saying so when joe gets here we'll
talk a little bit more about it but it's
ranger's birthday so everyone make sure
that you wish ranger happy birthday
yeah we did little dog treats and stuff
he
didn't give a [ __ ] he just was like i'm
hungry
all right thank you thank you very much
my friend i appreciate